okay i have one word for our next star
icon yes how about legend oh you know
about that
for sure yes we are talking about shania
twain oh my gosh and can you believe
it's been 25
years since her breakthrough album the
woman in me skyrocketed her career
and to celebrate the milestone shania
will be releasing the woman in me
diamond edition tomorrow featuring 16
previously
unreleased tracks yes and though shania
loves looking back she tells seniors she
whispers her hair
could have been a little bit more tape i
could not
stop staring at this photo of you
when you look at this photo what do you
see who is this person
in this shot
it's somebody with frizzy hair
it's really fun looking back
you know i had so many wonderful
experiences putting the woman in me
together
i could never have imagined the impact
that any of this was going to have
yeah i was just putting my best foot
forward i was in the pursuit
of originality
[Music]
pushing my own limits as well liberating
myself in a lot of ways i was using
my music platform as a deeper
self-expression
than maybe even i was comfortable with
all the time pushing my limits
it was a really growing time for me i
was learning a lot i was getting
a huge education very very very fast
[Music]
have you ever considered doing a body
pick on your life
i have i think i will do it it's just um
when will i do it i have no idea there's
so much
emotionally tied to doing something like
that uh you know the one question you
love people asking others
is are you okay so i'm going to say ask
that question to you
are you okay i'm i'm more than okay i'm
doing really great
i'm happy uh with my new recovered
voice that is different my son is
amazing
he's 19 years old now so celebrating 19
years of parenthood
i'm in a beautiful marriage you know my
career is
is keeping me active and stimulated
and i'm healthy enough to still ride
horses and enjoy athleticism
i'm making a new album i'll i'll be able
to share new music with my fans soon
ah the list is long i'm doing more than
okay
you're also working on a tv show where
you're being executive producer to heart
of texas
and this is a story that's based on
siblings losing their parents
trying to save their ranch i'm assuming
this really resonated with you why was
it important for you to be part of this
project
so this is just another platform for me
to grow in experiment with experience
the heart of texas book series which is
you know the parallel to me you know
a young family living in their hearts
and having to
make things work uh without with that
rug being pulled out from under the feet
you know just all of the drama that goes
with that the ups and downs
and i'm i love the characters in the
story
so i'm looking forward to diving into
that to writing music for it
and to riding horses on set i can't wait
it leopard suits yes yes
oh oh yeah okay that's a good one i'm
gonna
maybe i should create like every time
i'm in a scene that i've got some sort
of hidden leopard print
somewhere in the next things